notion
uh towards conic stability so
here uh if f is f with
complex coefficient is stable if uh
it has no roots in the upper
half plane
so uh we can uh
redefine this definition of stability
saying that f is stable
if and only this
this set intersection with
positive orthant is
empty now what is this set this set
is a is a is a set of
vectors of imaginary parts of
roots of f
so first time it was observed by jurgens
theobald and
wolf and they asked themselves that
whether this can be generalized
because we see here there are two
objects one of them is cone
and other one is the set
which we call imaginary projection of a
polynomial
so let's look at the imaginary
projection of polynomials
they said this is
the set of vectors of imaginary parts of
roots of a polynomial f we call this
imaginary projection because there is an
underlying projection
which maps from r to the power
to n to rn and here is
one example of a imaginary projection of
polynomial this and
idea of computing imaginary projection
briefly
we have to extract a real part of
polynomial and imaginary part of
polynomial
this and then
we need to compute the range of y
uh such that the polynomial in x i will
have
real solution and if you do that we see
the nice picture
which says that outer part of this
circle
provides us the imaginary projection of
this polynomial
and instead of plus one it will choose
here
minus one which represents the chronic
ellipse or circle then
we'll have the imaginary position as
inter
plane rn if we are drawing then in a
plane
entire plane
now this is another um
example which shows us that imaginary
projections of hyperbolic conic sections
it gives us hyperbolic conic section so
here we conclude some properties of
imaginary projection
it is a semi algebraic set as it can be
thought of as the projection of a real
algebraic variety
it is not always closed it is always
unbounded for n greater equal to 2
and if the polynomial is irreducible
then oops then
the math um i initial projection
is always connected because the map is
continuous map one
oops this is the map one
and the uh jorgen's theoretical they
have also
observed that components of the
complement
they are always convinced convex and
finite in number
and this com complement of imaginary
projection
they have a um crucial
part in chronic stability
here is another motivation comes from
the theory of animals
where people are interested to study the
logarithmic
images of complex variety for in general
uh loader polynomial and
in our setup we are interested to look
at imaginary projection
one can look at real projection as well
but uh it gives the same result and
if we stick to imaginary uh projection
then
we can relate the results
which are already known for stable
polynomials
so now we are ready to define the notion
of conics stability
so we can choose a proper cone
by proper i mean four dimensional close
pointed code
a multivariate polynomial f with complex
coefficient
is called conic stable if
its imaginary projection of that
polynomial
has empty intersection with the interior
of the cone
k similarly
we can recall the definition of
stability
here it will assume the cone as the
non-negative earth encode
here are some examples like we can
uh define pst stable polynomials if we
consider the cone as
the cone of positive semi definite
matrix
then we will get a pst stable polynomial
when the variable our symmetric matrix
variable
and one can define pst stability with
complex coefficient
with respect to cycle upper half space
and here is another um class of
polynomials determinant polynomials
which generate
chronic stability and this is already
known uh due to borsy and brandon that
determinant polynomial is
real stable or the zero polynomial if
the coefficient matrices matrices aj are
uh positive semi-definite and a zero
this is hermitian
and in our setup we'll see there is a
larger class of
determinant polynomials which will be
conic stable polynomials
even though they need not be stable
polynomials
naturally some question arise here
whether the class of stable polynomials
is contained inside the class of pst
stable polynomials
answer is no not necessarily not all
stable polynomials are
pst stable here is one example
and not only a determinant of uh
determinant condition is not necessary
condition for a
stable polynomial for a polynomial to be
uh psd stable polynomial so this is
one example determine the polynomial
which which is um
not stable but psd then we ask that
whether determinant condition is a
necessary condition
for a polynomial to be psd that also
turns out to be wrong
not all determinant polynomials are pst
stable
here is one example
now uh let's uh look at
hyperbolic polynomial if uh with regal
coefficient it's a homogeneous
homogeneous polynomial it is called
hyperbolic with respect to direction e
if uh e is not a 0 and as
we have seen that inhibited polynomial
this should
have all roots real roots
f is if uh we have a hyperbolic
polynomial then there is always a
hyperbolic
hyperbolicity cone associated with it
which says the set of points
for which the polynomial universe
polynomial will have
always negative roots
and it is also known due to girding that
this hyperbolicity cone is open and
convex
then in this direction uh a remarkable
result
proved that hyperbolicity cones of f
coincide with the complement components
of
if complement components of if
and using this we have
uh we can say that hyperbolic polynomial
is always conic stable with respect to
this
cone hyperbolic silicon
so for a hyperbolic polynomial to be
conic stable
there are equivalent condition
like f is hyperbolic with respect to
every point in interior of the cone k
and another equivalent condition says
that
interior k should be contained inside
hyperbolicity cone with respect to some
direction e
i need to define one technical term like
initial form of
f denoted by in f um
it's the sum of the terms of f with
multi-degree d
if the polynomial has degree d that's
what it means
so then our first observation was that
if we start with a degree d polynomial
which is determinant
and its coefficient matrices are
hermitian matrices
and we know there exists one direction e
ah along that direction the span of the
coefficient matrices is positive
definite
then we can say that initial of f
is hyperbolic which is very
straightforward and second
have every hyperbolicity cone of initial
of f is contained inside the complement
of imaginary projection of
f and here is the idea of the proof
[Music]
so maybe i'll skip due to the time
constraint
so let's go to quadratic polynomials
our next result we actually derive
one well known result which says that
hyperbolicity cones are hyperbolicity
cones defined by quadratic polynomials
they are always spectrohedral and we
prove that
if we start with a quadratic polynomial
f
where the matrix representation a
has n minus 1 positive eigenvalue and
one negative eigenvalue then there
exists
one linear from l l
such that this will have
a determinant of representation and we
have a recipe to
generate this l of z linear form
l this uh
theorem is based on three uh steps
first we realize that any quadratic form
in our
real quadratic they can be classified
into
one of these three normal forms
then one of these normal forms
so then we compute the imaginary
projection of the polynomial
which turns out to be the open low range
cone
this is in plane it looks like this
ice cream cone and then third one
we use the fact that open low range cone
has spectro hetero representation
and note that the initial of g which is
the normal
form of f using standard
for reduction formula we can
get this normal form from
starting with the f like this
then use this classification and
find the initial um projection of
f which has two unbounded chronic
components
which are actually open launch cone and
it's negative
and also knowing the fact that they have
spectrohydral representation we can
generate this l linear form
here it gives us one
key idea to lead to our main result of
this paper
it says uh that we observe that if we
have spectral representation for the
cone k
and the chronic components of complement
of imaginary projection of f
then we can translate this chronic
stability
problem into a problem of spectra
heterocontainment
that means we need to see whether
this is if both of them has
spectrometrical representation
so it turns out to be checking
um spectrophetyl contaminant in order to
check whether
polynomial f is conic stable or not
and non-negative orthogon they have
spectrohydral representation
positive semi-definite cone they also do
have spectral
representation uh associated with the
linear matrix polynomial of this
form where
jj entry is 1 and rest of the entries
are
zeros and in this case it's just
we can think of half of e i e j
transpose
plus e j e i transpose these are these
are the matrices
and um e is is a standard vector
so we do have spectral representation
for non-negative orthogon
as well as positive independent cone we
use that fact
and using this setup like we can
write a spectro header suppose we have
linear matrix pencil u
x and v x and that generates this
spectro hetero
u s u and s p then
we can define a linear map
from the space of um currently u
to v which maps um
which maps positive semi-dependent
matrix from
curly u to positive semi-dependent
matrix to curly key
so it's a positive map
and then we used this
uh well-known result about spectrohedral
contaminant it says that
this positive map is um this linear map
is positive
if and only corresponding
spectro hetero is one of them is
contained inside other one
it has another known fact that it is
associated with
one semi-definite feasibility problem
which says that there should exist
one positive simultaneous matrix
and the coefficient matrix v p
which is associated with this
spectrohedral
they can be always represented as linear
combination
of matrix pencil associated with
s u but this
only provides sufficient condition so
here using this fact
we derive our main result which also
provides sufficient criteria for a
polynomial to be conic stable
it says that if we start with a
determinant of polynomial
whose coefficient matrices are hermitian
then
and we have this two condition initial
operator
is it is irreducible and it is
hyperbolic
and also we know the cone k has
spectro hetero representation which is
this
then we theorem claims that if there
exists
a hermitian block matrix c which is also
known as
choi matrix it's a block matrix
this c and with this combination
then always f is k stable or conic
stable
and this theorem is mainly based on the
fact that
we can always write hyperbolicity cone
associated with initial f
which is denoted as this which would
give
this form this linear matrix tensor
that can be written as category of
product
of amx which is the
spectra hydrogen linear matrix pencil
associated with the
spectrohedral representation of the cone
k
and the choli matrix c so now it turns
out that we have to
uh decide whether such a matrix block
matrix c
exist or not and which is a
semi-definite feasibility problem
then uh here it's like
we can see as a special case it
gives us the well-known result which i
mentioned before
the determinant of polynomial due to
boshia brandon
uh determinable polynomial is real
stable if and only if the coefficient
matrix associated with this
they are positive semi-definite because
we can
view chowi matrix as
a block diagonal matrix whose non
diagonal
in blocks are 0s then
the condition here 4
gives us this condition
which says that each coefficient matrix
aj
have to be it has to be positive same
definite
here is one example um
of determinant representation we knew
that
and then we found the joy matrix which
proves that this this is actually a
conic stable polynomial
and here another fact is that um
we can use this result reversely like
if we know there exist a choi matrix and
the polynomial is conic stable somehow
we know this
um matrix by uh
checking or by solving a semi definite
programming
then from this we can compute
the determinant representation of
quadratic polynomials
this results only so far we have been
able to
um proved for quadratic
polynomials as you can see this
block 4 1 1
8
and here are some um open problems
actually this is a new topic um there
are lots of things to be done
uh characterization it's not yet
complete we have so far
given one sufficient condition and that
too based on
eat the cone and in complement of
imaginary projection
they have spectrohedral representation
closer property i mean operations which
preserve conic stability that is uh
still open
and whether there is any connection with
log concave polynomials or not that part
is
not yet clear we didn't get much time to
solve this part and another thing is we
are hoping that if someone can
generalize
um hyperbolic programming using chronic
stability
conic stable polynomials and their
associated their
cone thank you thank you for your
attention
here i will stop
and if you have any question
i can thanks um
any questions
so do you think there's a nice
characterization of psd stability
preservers
we hope so it's not yet
done in our paper
and thurston is also here i hope
so please if you have
any question please ask us
so maybe let me mention on these
stability preservers because there was
this question
i mean there are many many kinds of uh
preservers and of course uh some
[Music]
simple natural ones uh generalized so
it's clear that they do not generalize
but
of course they are i would agree with
that what papri said that many of these
questions are still open so
so this seems somehow like uh mario
mentioned this
conjecture of of tonsil which was that
if you take a hyperbolic polynomial uh
yeah if you take a hyperbolic polynomial
and then you can look at
[Music]
um
well okay so his talk was about given um
[Music]
a given a i guess a
cone you can define the set of matrices
with eigen values in that cone
and if that cone is hyperbolic
then uh the set of such matrices is a
cone which is again a hyperbolicity code
right yeah
so that's like a purely geometric
statement and what you're doing seems to
be like
something like that but at the level of
the polynomials
or i mean is there any if there's some
is there not some relation between these
things uh
uh thurston uh if you have anything
you can say because right now on top of
my head i don't
know how to connect them but i would be
interested to see any connection
between them so of course i can comment
from my side
so i uh i i i did not
see mario's talk but just uh i mean saw
the abstract and so
uh i mean of course whenever it comes to
hyperbolic polynomials
um there's this connection natural
connection towards
chronic stability uh i mean there are
slight differences in the model because
uh
i mean in the stability business one
also allows
non-homogeneous polynomials and so on
but
uh generally i mean it's something like
uh some kind of a
sharpening of the hyperbolicity notion
because uh in the
conic stability viewpoint one kind of
asks what kind of cone is contained
inside the hyperbolicity cone
this is how you can view it
geometrically so therefore whenever it
comes to
hyperbolic polynomials uh you might ask
the more precise question with respect
to
um what kind of cones are really really
inside so therefore
there is a natural connection towards uh
mario's investigations
so you're looking at you want the
basically the one
the difference here is you're looking at
this imaginary projection
and then your uh i mean
yes so this is something like a um a
more extensive and more comprehensive
view on all the hyperbolic
uh business and uh
it gives you kind of more information i
would say and of course
yeah it's interesting to study these
refined views